take this lollipop you tell us about
that that's this interactive Facebook
thing
take this Olli cop is the most
successful Facebook application of all
time now he said over 70 million hits
and a commercial director named Jason
sada created it he also created an
application which plays every Christmas
called elf yourself which you may have
seen we have little elves dancing and
you put your family member's face on it
so Zanna came up with the idea for take
this lollipop it's his baby
he made Facebook has a API guidelines
for their applications and he and his
team very creatively made an application
that would do things Facebook never
thought it could be done but all within
their guidelines and so he created this
application in which you give it
permission to access your profile just
as you do with any Facebook application
suddenly you're in a dark hallway you're
over the shoulder of a very creepy guy
sweaty grungy bastard and a wife beater
he's trying to hack into somebody's
facebook profile oh my god he's and
whose profile
and he goes from there he looks at your
friends he's pawing the screen he's
really agitated and then he's looking up
the map to see where you live and it
ends with him driving in a car coming to
get you with your facebook profile
picture taped to his dashboard so I got
that role and it helped quite a bit
because essentially it was a two minute
commercial for what I do best on camera
and it's been very good I'm very
grateful to Jason SATA for it
you